oliver franco wird sterns zugeschaltet
ist aus tel aviv er franco wird ich
grüße sie ganz herzlich
das schön dass sie an dem sehr späten
abend bei ihnen zu hause
nach einer langen schicht arbeit heute
noch mit uns sprechen uns zugeschaltet
sind der franco wird arbeitet als
pfleger in einem altenheim als deutscher
pflege an einem israelischen altenheim
pflegt dort unter anderem holocaust
überlebende
sagen sie uns ganz kurz am anfang
wichtigste frage ist es aktuell ruhig
bei ihnen in bezug auf raketenbeschuss
auf raketenalarm also ich bin jetzt
gerade bei mir daheim nicht in tel aviv
im rahmen einer stadt zwischen tel aviv
und jerusalem das speller ebene jetzt
gerade ist so ruhig heißt wir haben kein
raketenalarm räumlich allerdings eine
eine dieser gemischten städte in der
ersten rede nach oder heute hier keine
raketen der frühschicht hatte ich im
heim das heimatland grenzt direkt
erschlichen
tel aviv an und dort werde ich morgen
und übermorgen die nacht verbringen
warum um die dort arbeitenden menschen
zu unterstützen im fall von raketenalarm
die mehr als 100 bewohnerinnen des heims
aus ihren zimmern aus ihren wohnungen zu
holen und einen relativ sicheren ort zu
bringen
sie haben da so was wie in raketen
notdienst sagen sie das heißt sie müssen
extra schicht schieben um diejenigen die
eben nicht mehr schnell oder gar nicht
mehr auf den beinen sind einigermaßen
zumindest in sichere räume zu bringen
innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit genau diese
die belegschaft in der nacht die
angestellten je nach dienst haben sind
nicht sind zu wenige um alle menschen
die im heim leben aus ihren zimmern zu
holen deswegen übernachten jede nacht
weitere mitarbeiter vom heim im heim
wohnungen und zimmern die dort frei
sehen
um im fall von einem raketenangriff zur
stelle zu sein und zu helfen
ich habe schon gesagt sie pflegen dort
unter anderem auch holocaust überlebende
in ihrem altenheim wir haben diese
sendung begonnen mit den bildern von
demonstrationen hier aus berlin von
eindeutig antisemitischen
demonstrationen ist das bei ihnen im
altenheim ein thema wird darüber
gesprochen kommen diese bilder dort an
altenheim in dem ich arbeite das sich
übrigens der eltern heim nennt gehört
der vereinigung der israelis
mitteleuropäischer herkunft an das wurde
gegründet für deutsche juden in den 1930
er jahren palästina geflüchtet sind und
dort somit begründet stadt ist und das
sind alles menschen die die juden
diskriminierung verfolgung in
deutschland miterlebt haben und außerdem
es in dem heim viele menschen aus
osteuropäischen ländern die außer der
folge noch die judenvernichtung
miterlebt haben jetzt sehen diese
menschen in den nachrichten und es wird
in jeder nachrichtensendung gezeigt an
die situation aus london aus paris und
auch aus berlin und es ist für diese
menschen besorgniserregend es ist
schockierend es ist entsetzlich
und es ist diesen menschen auch nicht zu
erklären warum das stattfinden kann
in deutschland oli sie realität mit
israel immer wieder als staatsräson
propagiert wird und dann wird trotzdem
geduldet dass auf den straßen israel und
den juden hamas hamas juden ins gas
skandiert wird diese menschen bekommen
das mit und müssen das mitbekommen
an ihrem lebensabend ich denke allein
das zufügen
in dieser demonstration zu verbieten